PRESIDENT FROM LEGALCRUTD DEFEN
CS.EPTLEN , THINGS APPARENTLY C
ASON N
THREE TIMES IN THE P DAS
DEFENSE IN THE MAR-A-LAGO
SEAR.TO ABOUT TICE DEPARTMENT'SC
T THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
SAID ALL ALONG, THERE 'V
MAKE OUA L ILL TH
AND I -- THARST SOMEBODY ON,
QUESTION.
EY'RE GETTININK AT THE END OF TC
PRESEN THE
COUNTRY?
WHAT KIND OF WSET?
PLREALLY
UNTA IS NOT
FAILING Y
BOOK, THAT TS S RR
USSEM INGS.I WOULD HOPE THO KORN
INDICTED.
E ECIARI SR ANHIEF " JONAH GOLD.
HEI APPRECTE
SHAN, LET ME START WITH YOU THE
THIS POINT OR AT LEAST THEY'RE
VE CWHAT DO YOD THE
>> WHAT'S BEHIND THE S
SHIFT I DON'T THINK IS ANYTHIN
PEOPLE AREINGN CRITICALS OF
FAMP
I THINK WHATE'S LFNG. TO POIF H
MOVE
FASTEY SHOULD MOVE FASON
THIS.
PROTECTING PDER.
I THINK IT'S KIND OF FOR
HIM TO SAY THAT RLISE PROSUTDIRE
EXERCISED IT SANTLY TO
IT'S QR .
>> JT DO YOU THINKG ON
YOU'ITICAL
OBSERVER
>> I THINK IT'S -- BILL TIMES,H
PORTRABYOTS ASASNEE
MES BY- HE CAME BY HIS SU
PRIDS AND TI AEORIES ABOUT THE .
I LOT OF HISONS, TACT ON
P.K NK PGS HE SAID OVEE LABEEN N
WHAT HE'S DOING HERE IS HE IS SE
THE CURRENPO
IND THAT'S THE CLEVER BY ST BEN
AND THAT'SHEW AT FROM.RII THINN
AVE M  -ANLE FORWHEND
AND MANY OTHERS WHO ECHO THAT E
, THE MEOV BUTN ON
PERSON
PERSON, WHEN HE TAE IGATIO
CLEAR THIS ETO
SOMEONE WITH OBSTRUCTCE, THAT H
N HIS STATEMENT
BOUN E RISETOEY
CAUSE, SHOUMEESIDENT BE INDICT?
YES.BE
NOW, THE POLITICS
OR NOT YOU CAN GET JURY TONO
QUESTION.
BUT THTHE D BE
DIR AT LEAST
>> YOUSWS THE ANSWER LIZ CHEGA
RY.SA
I IZE.
ARE A LOT OFARNS OF LIZ EN ACTU.
THE POCS IT WOULD ANRE, INA VAL
ON OUST  O TIT'S NERT TH ABOVE
BELOW THE LAI THINK IS THE
WRG
HEAR ALL OVER THPLACE.
IT IS -- THERE JUST A ENT STAND.
THIOE
>> HE'S INT.
BUT MY TREAT PR TRAYS.
PE- N S A IL
EASCTMR
ESAM ACTUALLY PARD  THEONDITI
IT WOULD BODWOULD HURT HIM
FOTH
ILCOURAG PTYR IC.
BUT, I TOTALLY RES
POLITICAL HAPOINT THOUGH, ONE OT
DIETRI RH  WHY WE'RE
HYE HAVE
DARD, WEEEOT JOEENMPLITICAL QUWH
POLITICAL AS A PSIR DOING.HE SH
BE POLITIC